Hello, and welcome to Computability,
Complexity, and
Algorithms, the introductory
theoretical computer science course for
the Georgia Tech Masters and
PhD programs.
I'm Lance Fortnow, professor in
the School of Computer Science
at the Georgia Institute of Technology.
>> And I'm Charles Brubaker,
a PhD graduate from Georgia Tech, and
Udacity course developer.
>> In this course,
we'll ask the big questions.
What is a computer?
What are the limits of computation?
Are there problems that no
computer will ever solve?
Are there problems that
can't be solved quickly?
What kinds of problems
can we solve efficiently?
And how do we go about
developing these algorithms?
Understanding the power and limitations
of algorithms helps us develop the tools
to make real world computers smarter,
faster, and safer.
We step away from the particulars
of programming languages and
computer architectures and instead
take an abstract view of computing.
This viewpoint allows us to understand
where the computation problem is
inherently easy or hard to solve.
Independent of the specific limitation
of a machine we plan to use.
These results have stood the test of
time, being as valuable to us today
as they were when they
were developed in the 70s.
While the topic of the course is theory,
understanding the material can
have very practical benefits.
You will learn a wealth of tools that
will help you recognize when problems
you encounter in the real
world are intractable and
when there is an efficient solution.
This can save you countless hours that
would otherwise have been spent on
a fruitless endeavor or
in reinventing the wheel.
Certainly by having followed the
rigorous arguments made in this course,
you'll have given yourself
a kind of training.
The athlete doesn't just
practice on the field or
the court where the competition is held,
he goes to the gym.
And when he returns, he finds he
is better prepared for the game.
In a similar way, by taking this course,
you'll improve your thinking,
as you make engineering, or
even business decisions.
You will find that you have better
reasons to prefer one strategy
over another, and
will be able to articulate more rigorous
arguments in support of your ideas.
Shall we get started?
>> Let's hit that gym!